We started this Unit by looking into some fundamental ideas
of finite elements and computational fluid dynamics.
These are two related and highly application-oriented field
that of particular use in mechanical engineering.
The toy model of fluid dynamics left to the notion of deterministic chaos--
the sensitive dependence on initial conditions, but we saw that randomness
can be produced virtually out of nothing.
Then we look into a range of topics from software engineering--
how can we build modules that can be mixed and matched, how can we reuse software,
and how do we calibrate and test simulations.
These questions eventually led us to a little bit of philosophy,
and now it's time to apply all of these in the final exam.